Welcome to Fitness Universe.
Hi! Could you tell me a little bit about your membership fees?
Are you interested in our one - year membership?
I'm going to be here for a year, so I guess that would be the best one to start with.
Okay. For a regular one - year membership,...
...the cost is $1,000.
Does that include use of all the facilities?
Yes, that includes use of the swimming pool and racquetball courts.
How about if I want a personal trainer?
Then your best bet would be to get a Gold Star membership.
With that, you get a personal trainer to work with you three times every week.
I see. How much is a Gold Star membership?
A Gold Star membership is $1,500 per year, sir.
Hmm... I think I'll just stick with the regular membership.